all right welcome to another edition of
beginner breakdown i am your host my
cover just back from a beautiful on Las
Vegas planet hollywood directing the a
millionaire chest open the real thing
with a million-dollar prize fund so
we'll be going over the future of
american chess today obviously the
present is a Nakamura the big champion
$100,000 richard congratulations to him
fabiano carry on oh and wesley so but
we'll be going over the future today and
the future of american chess is good i
watched it and a lot of a lot of good
chest being played right now i'm going
to go over a game I played in Ferguson
today against one of my students this is
their fifth class and they finally know
how to make legal moves and so forth but
I want to go over these games real quick
before the millionaire chess games to
show how how to teach the kids to get
them to get them good so the first
things you want to do is a note 8 the
game you don't want to be giving them
hints during the game you want to let
them make the mistakes and then go over
the mistakes with them afterwards okay
so here we go so I had the white pieces
efore e5 Knight f3 keep in mind they've
only been playing for well they about a
week now so Queen to g5 obviously not a
good move so you just take it you just
take okay hey bring out the night Bishop
c4 g6 so obviously check okay so King up
so you get castled and you explain a
great castle Bishop h3 not a good move
right so don't put your pieces where
they can get captured alright i'm
showing you this for a reason and it
will become clear in just a second so
they take
upon okay not bad d for another horrible
move Knight to d2 and you just take ok
and then so they take and I play check
ok King to c8 bishop e6 check and they
realize hey there's only one way to get
out 97 alright and this is the reason
why I showed you this game so I play
Queen to h5 okay so obviously every move
she's made has been probably not
recommended right right but now you know
I wasn't taking easier honor no Gabe and
she's like why did he play that move
that's what she said and and she sees
wow he's threatening checkmate so she
ate there's there's a couple different
ways you can get out of the checkmate
Bishop e7 King up or she just plays g6
you know so so good for her you know
that that's why you don't take it easy
you let let them figure it out as they
go you don't be oh you should you should
stop to check me you let them figure it
out that's the way they get better and
unfortunately she doesn't see that c6
stops this and she goes on to Toulouse
pretty fast King b8 take her stuff and
she doesn't play the best move here but
may but but you know you go over the
game then and tell her what she did
right alright so so here's the future of
American chess right here it's his name
is Jonah Romero he played in the under
2,000 section nineteen hundred and you
know I'm sure when he was getting taught
as a as a child nobody was taking easy
on him you know he just have to figure
it out on your own so here was playing
in the you two thousand he's a 1909 he
was playing against a chess expert who
they let in to the under 2,000 category
legally Jonah had the white pieces and
let's see how he does all right so he
starts out the Queen's pawn very good
night f6 and ce4 excellent so black
plays c5 and whenever they do this if
you if you're a deep pond player push it
whenever they play c5 against you you
just push it up okay don't take it don't
let him trade it off just push it up all
right e 6 night up takes takes and
whites looking pretty good here and d6
you protect the pond he's got a look at
all his bishops are nice and free
threatening checks or he doesn't want to
be checked with a six so whenever your
opponent plays the move a six okay well
one it is stopping players from getting
the b5 right but it's also threatening
b5 itself so this is excellent that he
plays to move a for you so now you know
he doesn't want to get his bishop like
that so so he decides to go ahead and
fianchetto it with a g6 here right
alright he plays the move h3 just as
comer would play here Ashley okay so h
three all right so so Bishop g7 Bishop
g5 all right pins the night and as we
know when they remove the [ __ ] about
your weakening the pond so he attacks it
easy easy easy we can just play Queen to
see two protects the pawn protects our a
pawn things are looking good Black gets
castled here and you know we bring the
night up and everything is good
all right unfortunately the Cardinals
just lost the tour big arch rival the
Chicago Cubs so if I'm a little
distracted I apologize okay all right so
it's black to play here if you were
going to bring out a night to d7 here
would you choose this night on this
night probably this night huh because
where else can I even go nowhere so so
very surprising that this guy rated 2049
Nico playing black chose to move that
night I guess he just did not want to
trade get that night taken so that's
what was played and so now it's white to
move here all right so so like in the
other game you know you know we do it
like attacks you know a five if it does
attack the Queen and the Queen has to
move now the c7 I probably would have
maybe played I just my bishop out and
maybe thought about getting castle but
oh right sorry attacks the Queen goes
back and now he plays Bishop to c4 so
when you put your bishop out there like
that obviously the player playing black
is just going to attack it gets a gets
an easy move here that you really
doesn't have to think about and look
when you're up material or where you're
not even up material but obviously it
doesn't take a rocket science just to
figure out hey white has a lot more
space than black in this position right
so the last thing you want to be doing
when you have more space is to let the
guy that's all cramped here trade pieces
right
I mean look once he got him go there
this night can't move this Bishop can't
move I mean this Queen sure she's old
she can't even move like none of his
pieces can move so so like you don't
really have to do much you can just a
castle and then let him try to untangle
himself so Bishop their castle get get
your rook to see one your other rook to
the e-file because look how is I mean
it's going to take black a long time to
a tongue cramp himself so by playing
Bishop to c4 you give this guy a very
easy move right like night up to attack
the bishop so now one of these pieces
are going to go all right so he's like
all right i'll just take so Bishop takes
now white gets castled and now black and
start trying to uncraft himself here 97
we have tack all right so check hang up
rook attacks the pawn so so this tactic
like if you would just waste a move here
ok say you waste the move the last thing
black would want to do here is trade
this bishop this dark squared bishop
because he's home holding together all
the mate threats because if Queen takes
look you're coming right down on g7 and
after Bishop h6 you're threatening a
really big checkmate here ok everybody
see that Queen to g7 mate so so when
you're playing with black and you
fianchetto you know your dark squared
bishop you should be very very cautious
about trading trading your dark squared
Bishop pretty much you want to trade
your dark square Bishop for his dark
squared bishop if you have to but if
he's got a dark square Bishop I would
even think twice about taking a look
for it because you know you can get a
check made it pretty easy without that
dark squared bishop okay so just
something to think about and so rookie
eight so 92 it's always like I want to
trade uh you know my night for your dark
squared bishop and he's like I don't
think so and he moves it back and so
it's like well okay i'll just go back
then and now black plays the dreaded f6
moo alright so f6 very dangerous move in
this position because look he's got a
light square Bishop actually leaned up
on on the same diagonal as the King here
so I've somehow who can get d 6 in you
just lost your queen all right so Bishop
h4 and Joy's like all right I'm going to
get my my king 2 h8 here let's see what
the computer has to say about this
really quick
no he doesn't have much to say it just
says White's winning all right so Bishop
out [ __ ] it back to g3 light update
Queen f'd who so now black decides to
play f5 so so okay so we just challenged
you with f5 right alright so so there's
allowed three three things maybe we
could consider okay we could consider
take we could consider push or maybe
protect okay what are we thinking
alright so if you take it looks like all
our pressure on the F file is over now
and he's got the e-file so that's
probably not good if we just protect I
mean that might be okay but best is just
let's push let's just go for it here
Saudi five so pawn takes pawn takes
Bishop takes we take rook takes and now
it's like we sacrifice a pawn here 1 2 3
4 5 6 25 but but now we've got a passed
pawn and and we're looking pretty good
here so so now we just sacrifice the
pond so we need something to happen
quick here so what can we attack of
blacks in this position and I'll give
you a hint it's already currently being
attacked by us but we want to attack
something again
and he guesses so so this is attack but
it's protected this is not attack this
is attacked by the Queen but it's
protected by the Queen can we get
anybody else helping out here how about
this night night 284 so he's threatening
a pawn and he's threatening to go to be
6 here okay so black actually play the
move I would play here which is funny
because I'm 1700 and he's 20 49 all
right so rook to uh II for all right so
so this is a move that I if I was
playing white in this position I would
have just jumped to be 60 k 1 you're
attacking the rook and two you're
protecting the bishop but maybe he
wanted to keep the pressure on uh on c5
so he plays be three you know protects
the bishop protects the night fair
enough but the player playing black Nico
has a decent move so he can
simultaneously protect this pawn and
protect b6 how do we do that and he
guesses yes Knight to d7 Thank You Keith
97 okay so so now Romero's plans are all
put on hold but he's not discouraged
he's not discouraged she's like all
right oh and now unfortunately this is
another move I disagree with Jonah
Romero here okay so if you're playing
white okay and you want to challenge the
e-file okay would you move the rook on a
one that's just been sitting there the
whole game doing nothing look at the
brook
Hana the app file who's backing up the
Queen obviously we would move the the a
rock but he plays the road work but
that's okay I mean he's young and he's
still learning and you know even a
corona he's 7 and 0 in the 2014
sinkfield cup and he moves the wrong
rook and gets a draw so it happens to
everybody okay even corona okay so so
you can look it up ground round eight he
moves the wrong rook maybe we member
will bring it up just a just a show move
the wrong rook buddy oh so and he's
doing that when he's you know on top of
the world seven and oh so happens
everybody alright so rook takes e4 F
takes e4 and now guess what white plays
here come on just say it what does he
play no no thank God thank God he's not
in a third grade anymore well he might
be he's young but yeah he does not play
this is this is this is a lot higher
level than a Ferguson chess over here so
uh so what uh what move does he play
that you know right obviously yes yeah
Brooke everyone right everybody just
played though Brooke ADA f1 in the e1 in
the first place you wouldn't have to
waste the move here nobody waits the
move and now it's cleans under attack so
we love scary moves and this this is
where I was impressed with him you just
go right up to his face you know Queen
up something I'm so close now and so
he's like 'i too if I was playing as
white in this position I wouldn't even
thought about this move I would have
snapped this so fast
because if he brings his queen out here
he's in a lot of trouble and it's
complicated to see you have to be as
good as me but take that pawn because
obviously this night can't move right
here we agree with that if the night
moves checkmate ok so we're sacrificing
a lot of material but he's in a lot of
trouble so now black can't move he like
I can't move Oh what if he tries that
though hmm what if he tries that does
our move still work probably six
and then this should just be our lights
out huh
yeah you got you got made seven just
figure it out but it starts with that
and then you'll be it you'll be aces all
right so it's going to be really really
tough for black to hold that position so
that's probably what what he probably
should have played but all right he
decides to be like super cautious and
just maintain the lead because if you
can't calculate out main seven you know
you might as well just keep keep your
winning edge right so rookie one Queen
f6 he takes Knight takes take the pawn
and life is good Bishop f5 so he's got
one two three four five it's 525 right
what the big difference is we got this
guy okay so do you think he's going to
be really good if he just sits there all
day and just just hangs out on a deep
I've let the night get behind it let the
bishop get behind it and that move no we
got to get them going eventually here
but let's see let's see what we got well
first things first we can take something
right what can we take for free here
then just take it yeah and now we're
threatening this guy okay so life is
good a good life is really good all
right so so now black is in desperation
mode he's like hmm I've got an idea I'll
put my night they're hoping that the kid
goes for the fork right and then what
would black play a big check yeah Big
Fork here and then we can either take us
night on the bishop it doesn't matter
and black would be winning so Jonah's
like I ain't going for that i'll attack
your pawn again he's like darn it
so rook f8 and now he gets the the pawn
fork and so takes takes now I guess the
check does nothing King up rook attacks
the night it's like I'll take that I'll
take it and now what move do we play to
just seal the deal here yeah I mean
everything's good but pushing the pawn
the fastest route he doesn't even play
the best moves excuse me if he even
plays the best moves it doesn't matter
Chuck I mean yeah just it's all right so
so it was good he knocked out the
highest rated player 2049 in this in the
under 2,000 section and then he was off
to round number three result 10 I've
adjudicated it yeah it's all good and I
Jonah is really good whenever anybody
asked him what color he wanted to be he
said I want to be white and so guess
what he got to be worried again all
right but here's a little kid from a New
Mexico rated 1909 I'm sure he gain some
points off of the millionaire open so
he's the future of American chest that's
who he is art so here we go so once
again he starts out d 4 and in Moby Dick
fans out there I no one I know one all
right
this guy taking all the jokes is taken
all the jokes what's this called the
bangko gambit I find all right so so
whenever they play the bank or game
would just take it right yeah and then
take it all and g6 in this position I
would protect the pawn with our III but
night up Bishop takes and now we can't
move our epon or else our bishop will
get captured so we have to fianchetto
the bishop here white is a Jonah sahil
Tikku 1997 nice all right good their
property of the TV are the organizer so
maybe there are maurices but I took a
laugh they're mine now alright Bishop up
Bishop g2 and notice unlike in the other
game the guy puts the right night on the
d7 so they both get castle and life is
good now maybe our prestigious
Grandmaster been fangled can explain
this one rook to be one oh yes okay okay
very good so so by burning your rook to
be one you get it off this dangerous
diagonal all right
I head up that's a truck a lot in
question that's like I don't have to
stick in any of these folks haha yeah
alright so this is a move I understand
put the bishop in the same diagonal as
the Queen all right so he's like all
right I put my bishop out Queen c2 and
now the Queen gets out of the diagonal
where it brings us pawn up and now
Bishop attacks the ruck so we move the
rook behind the pawn that's not
protected by another part all right so
night 2g okay yes a lot of people
wouldn't buy three before you for to
prevent that and that's a good idea to
switch my place before g3 is weeks and I
g45 so some people would have played a
tree so in this position been fangled is
saying play my favorite move h3 and then
you can't go there very good but that
didn't happen as we see and now black
gets in Knight to g4 but if he plays h3
now what's the follow which is probably
not what happens now he decides to push
his up a spawn and now black gets his
Knight to e5 takes takes and now he
brings his night up attacks the Queen so
he doubles the pawns attacks the pawn
why consolidates
and now he challenges the a file here
now what move would you play as black
here there's three options you can give
them the a file but we have obviously
you can double the rooks or you can just
retreat the rook that's what I said but
but this guy's like I'm going to play
more like ripka recommended because if
you doubled the rooks he's like he'll
just take it and then the computers like
that's not good so sometimes you have to
listen to the computer but i don't i
don't know why i would have doubled the
rooks but in this position it's
screaming for rook a back and that's
actually what's played in the game which
looks unnatural but he's playing like
Houdini so it can't you can't I can't
say nothing alright so Bishop to see
three you can obviously in all this
bedside okay so so Bishop up alright so
now he's putting them to the test rook
to a sex he's daring them to UND's and
he goes for it now rook to a eight rook
behind the pawn rook stops it so what is
an idea for white to do in this position
how are we going to ever move this pawn
because it looks stuck huh
okay well what's wrong with Bishop to a
five in this position yeah that's a
bummer but we really liked his idea
though right Bishop a5 Bishop be six
right I love his idea but it just
doesn't work because he'll take the pawn
so what moves should we play in this
position if only haha that's a tough one
excellent yes yes all right so so Bishop
f1 yes yeah he's the future of American
chess all right so night after we check
he's like I don't care I don't care he
actually said that to the guy alright so
now the night go he goes back oh yeah he
was joking he was joking he wrote Knight
to e5 just a fool his opponent in kc was
like looking at as notation okay so
night the d4 even though it says 'i five
that's extra where it goes so we don't
want to take this we don't even though
well we just don't want to take it right
we want we want to go with our own plan
Bishop a five he's like I got a fork now
what do we do do we panic or do we keep
on with our own ideas yeah it's always a
bad idea to panic so we have a great
idea right but he gave us a fork we do
not have to move the rook we can make a
threat just as good as his so Bishop
attacks the rook and now he's like okay
hmm it's like all right I'm going back
to AAA so now he goes rook a three
attacks the night so he protects it but
is that a very solid uh yeah just take
take you up free point but now i can
jump as night to c5 and so now he's like
give me that
pawn takes I get that pawn as far up as
possible because if you played any other
move here King up 3f for you can play
rook a seven and he's still doing pretty
bad but for the ball is you don't even
want to let them you're like you're
gonna your work is going to be stuck on
a eight buddy alright so now [ __ ] up
the d4 okay okay because if we move our
bishop right he'll just move this pawn
right and if we take he'll take and
you'll be happy so let's see what the
future of America has to say about this
what do you think he plays here you can
be a hero if you listen to ben fangled
yes d 6 but that is like in your face
buddy i'm playing e6 and not letting
your bishop go so do you think we're
marrows like oh I don't know may I my
all my plans of getting my bishop to
attack your rook are done I should just
give up the chess game draw yeah just
push the pond right pass pawns push them
right that's how they become powerful
and then black plays king of fate push
it again right well he doesn't even let
him push the point Portia's King to f8
and then he pushed it to e8 with the
resignation but but you wanted to get
that last move in there but but yeah we
will just play d7 and then we've check
them Queen rook rook takes rook takes
check and then the game's over okay so
that's the future American chest and his
name is nap Julian proly co all right
all right good night everybody
Oh